our education system that our public
education system is designed it is
designed in this country to keep limit
to keep mediocracy
is that did I say that right meaty
mediocracy mediocracy mediocracy
as the goal you have to be confused with
a meritocracy meritocracy I don't mean I
mean
colonoscopy or colonoscopy being
mediocre yeah
serious because what happened the public
education system is designed to keep you
in line and it's designed for you to
follow common knowledge well it I mean
it like even even like because that's
salacious why does my five-year-old have
to be in school at 8 A.M yeah but also
it's a function of
how we structure our day but where does
that come from why can't our day start
at 10 A.M